hey really quick you should check out
our sponsor the Janus SmartWatch
designed by Kronos blade I love mine you
can download any Android app make phone
calls watch videos track your heart rate
it has GPS it has a dual camera for
pictures videos and video calls and one
of the biggest screens out there 1.6
inches
check it out using the link right below
I don't know where Donald Trump's
impeachment will ultimately end other
than to say as I've said before it's
really unlikely that impeachment is
going to actually force Donald Trump out
of the White House through an
impeachment conviction I don't see that
as even remotely likely but the
possibility of an impeachment inquiry
and proceedings in the house is
increasing every day and it actually
could be damaging enough to Donald Trump
to help remove him in 2020 every single
day since the testimony of former
special prosecutor Robert Muller last
week we have seen more and more
Democrats say I support an impeachment
inquiry and I support it now by the
latest count 105 Democrats in the House
of Representatives support starting an
impeachment inquiry of Donald Trump now
as a reminder an impeachment inquiry is
only step one in order to remove a
president via impeachment you need an
impeachment inquiry which leads to
formalizing the impeachment proceedings
then you have an investigation and a
trial after which the Senate has to vote
to convict with a two-thirds majority so
we're very very far from that it is
extraordinarily unlikely we are going to
get to that but we may well get and we
could even argue that Jerry Nadler has
already de facto started an impeachment
inquiry let's look at some examples of
Democrats who are now saying they're in
favor of this one example is congressman
danny heck who said on twitter quote
after considerable reflection and
prayerful consideration don't know why
you need to pray to god to figure this
one out it's pretty clear I have decided
to support a formal impeachment inquiry
another example congresswoman Kim
Schreyer who said the people of the
eighth District of Washington elected me
to protect their health care and our
environment those will always remain my
focus while I have the privilege of
serving them in Congress they also
helped me elected me
uphold the Constitution so I am formally
calling for an impeachment inquiry this
is now a de facto miniature get out the
vote campaign within Democrats in the
House of Representatives because the
number right now is a hundred and five
Democrats want an impeachment inquiry
informally they haven't signed on to
anything but they have said this is what
we want there are 435 seats in the House
of Representatives half is 217 plus one
there are 235 Democrats Republicans are
not needed in order to start an
impeachment inquiry that is important to
remember here is Judiciary Committee
Chairman Jerry Nadler admitting that
there are currently impeachment
resolutions before the committee that
are being considered meaning this is
very close to getting going so so how
much this debate over whether or not the
house is in pursuing impeachment is a
semantic debate you have an impeachment
inquiry going don't you we are examining
I'll just repeat what we have said in
our court filings we argue that we have
impeachment resolutions before the
committee we are in conducting
investigations to determine whether we
should report those impeachment to
resolutions to the house of whether we
should draft our own and report them to
the house we are considering those
resolutions and we will make a
determination after we get more evidence
as to the president's crimes that we had
from the report but also as to other
things as to his violations of the
emoluments clause importantly even Nancy
Pelosi has sort of changed her tune
about impeachment if not her substantive
position she now says that the house
would decide whether to begin
impeachment proceedings quote when we
have a best strongest possible case
suggesting that maybe she's
understanding that there could be a
strategic timing element to this entire
thing yet she is still saying that the
time for the impeachment inquiry is not
right now which 105 other Democrats are
saying is the case but she has started
to shift her language around as well so
understand that any day any day with
relatively little notice
we might learn
that the house has launched an
impeachment inquiry and if you thought
that Donald Trump's behavior has been
erratic the last two and a half years
you ain't seen nothing yet just wait
until Donald Trump's behavior explodes
if indeed this gets going now it's
important to understand I've said it
before and I'll say it again impeachment
is not without risk there's the facts of
the situation and there are the
political considerations as I've said
before the facts more than support an
impeachment inquiry in particular Donald
Trump's endless obstructive acts to
which Robert Mulder testified last week
Donald Trump's violations of the
emoluments clause I would even argue
that Donald Trump's actions in Yemen may
be impeachable I did a segment about
this about a month or six weeks ago and
it is not receiving nearly the attention
as a sort of fodder for impeachment that
it probably should now given that there
is not a path to an impeachment
conviction with the current Republican
Senate there are ways in which a failed
impeachment attempt could hurt Democrats
and emboldened Trump that's a real thing
it's important to understand that the
ideal scenario is that the impeachment
inquiry itself is what exposes Donald
Trump's wrongdoing and it takes over the
news cycle Trump is meanwhile trying to
run for re-election and yet media
because of the impeachment inquiry is
focused on what comes out of that that's
the ideal scenario and in the end you
hope that the publicity around what
Donald Trump has done in the content of
the Moller report and the what would be
oh just a treasure trove of horrible
realities that would be exposed by the
impeachment inquiry would get people not
to vote for Trump in 2020 in the end
when you really think it through it sort
of should be an a political decision for
our elected officials to make what I
mean by that is I understand Democrats
thinking through the strategy of an
impeachment inquiry and the timing of an
impeachment inquiry but Congress is
supposed to keep the executive branch in
check the best argument I've heard for
why the impeachment inquiry must start
and it must start now is simply that
it's the job of Congress
period the political calculation I
understand
it's important I'm okay with Democrats
timing the impeachment inquiry to do
maximum damage to Trump for electoral
purposes but in the end the best
argument for why this impeachment
inquiry should get going is that it is
the duty of Congress period and that all
political considerations should become
secondary or even irrelevant to that
decision I know that it's not practical
in this highly politicized and partisan
world in which we live but it is the job
of Congress to do this
105 Democrats now say it's time to get
it going